deliberative theatre is a method of
public deliberation and discussion
developed a carnegie mellon university
by alumni shannon deep in conjunction
with the campus conversations program
run by johanna dicker in the Dean of
Student Affairs Office the structure of
a deliberative theatre event is as
follows a sample of the affected
population is taken and is administered
a pre survey about their thoughts on an
issue then they are presented with a 20
to 30 minute theatrical performance that
addresses the issue at hand then they
engage in small group discussion with a
moderator followed by a plenary session
in which they can ask questions to an
expert resource panel more group
discussion follows and finally the
participants take a survey to gauge how
their opinions have or have not shifted
over the course of the deliberation the
purpose of the event is to allow the
participants to become more informed
about and engaged in an issue and to do
so in a way that stimulates their
imagination as well as their intellect
through the campus conversations program
the first deliberative theatre event was
produced on campus in October 2010 about
the semester ly screenings of adult
films by the Activities Board film
committee the performance explored
issues relevant to showing such films on
college campuses issues of body image
sexual taboos and realistic expectations
the connection between sex and violence
and whether pornography was appropriate
for the academic environment
the video you see here was from a
restaging of her performance done in
February 2011 it is the number one rule
of storytelling to show don't tell
deliberative theatre shows here on stage
are people dealing with and working
through the same issues that
participants may be struggling with
themselves here on stage or real lines
of thought your reactions real
interactions between people by
presenting hypothetical interactions
between the various moving parts of a
complex issue deliberative theatre
reveals how seemingly abstract issues
are experienced in people's everyday
lives as participants come to appreciate
various ways in which perspectives
impositions lead to concrete actions and
interactions they develop a more
informed understanding of the issue
you